And she had a real job.
Fuck.
Oh No,
no.
Joe Rogan Experience Day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Big City Watch.
Oh Shit.
Do that one.
Yeah,
that was crazy.
Oh,
that fucking song.
Good Dude.
I'm three false.
No,
but I can tell you know what you're doing.
It's cool.
It's nice to see
you're hitting all the right shots.
It's cool.
I love the smell.
The smell of what?
The smell plot.
Oh yeah.
I like the smell.
It's like I've always like not been into the high that much,
but I'd loved everything about the drug.
Like the leaves growing yet.
Yeah,
rolling joints.
I mean when I was younger.
Right.
Yeah,
like it.
I'm a big fan.
I think it's just different.
No ball look perfect in one.
Cool.
Seeing someone who knows how to play pool.
Yeah.
I wish [inaudible] practice with a couple logic Garcia,
but he lives kind of far.
I'd be happy to play with you and what do you live?
I'm right now,
I'm living in
Yucaipa,
California.
Do you know what that is?
No.
It's on the way to palm springs.
It's kind of up in the house,
in the mountains,
more of a mountain.
He kind of vibe.
What are I brought you out?
Um,
because he told me about the house and uh,
I
like the idea that I could fit a regular pool table in there.
Isn't it all the high born like three or four houses.
I've never had one that had the room that would accommodate up,
want to have by nine.
There's always a,
so,
you know,
just,
I don't know what,
wow.
Yeah,
that's huge for me,
man.
It's one of the things I liked about this office.
Okay.
One of the things that I was excited about what this office is,
I knew there was space for a table.
I resisted for a while.
Nice.
Get it.
I'll just be fucking playing all the time and I wasted,
my life hasn't really been,
this is a great table of practice on the pocket.
So yeah.
No,
I enjoy it.
I think it's changed my game a little.
Do be running out like crazy on your diamond.
Yeah.
Well I saw also feel like I'm hitting balls a lot more gently.
I notice that some of the shots you good job making the,
it was just um,
it requires more of you because they're so tight.
I wasn't sure if that would be good or if it'd be annoying after awhile,
but I definitely think it's good.
Go Buddy.
Yeah.
It just requires acquires you to concentrate more.
Is it pockets?
You're stuck.
Rude.
We've got to make the right choices too.
Yeah.
How do you plan on 10 ball?
Do you play the back house?
We get 10 ball.
That's not supposed to count.
I think it's supposed to be called pocket.
Where did this play goes?
Goes through.
I like slot.
Okay.
I think like 10 ball.
I got to show you the shot that this guy,
he showed me something and I didn't hear it.
CJ,
why?
They talk about it for a long time,
but I've tried it and it's,
it's so bizarre to me.
I'll show you.
I just
get
such a nice job.
I think that's one of the coolest things about is the fact that you're trying to
control just a couple revolutions out a ball like that little bit off.
That's what makes the game so insane.
Yeah.
If you were just a little bit further than that,
it was a perfect shot.
Reckless.
You don't have to look this year,
did street,
do you know what Max,
I believe?
Oh yeah.
The guy that'd be a good guy to get instructions from
good.
Helped me a lot.
Get a lot of knowledge.
Well,
his fundamentals are so perfect.
Yeah.
The way he holds a cue,
he describes it as the reputation,
you know,
the reputation,
but he says,
you know,
the same amount of time between shots.
Yeah.
Good.